the challenges facing our world are
growing all the time
how do we build stronger economies with
equal opportunities for all how do we
build a sustainable world for
generations to come
how do we protect our cities and harness
the power of technology for our common
benefit
Humanity has always been good at Forward
Thinking we will make sense of the
problems of tomorrow
inequality
sustainability
urbanization the gender gap and the
demographic time bomb
[Music]
the world is changing
today we stand on the brink of a fourth
Industrial Revolution one that will
transform the way we work the way we
live and even what makes us human
there's a group of technologies that are
combining to create transformation
across almost every industry at the
moment and those Technologies include
things like artificial intelligence 3D
printing robotics big data and then some
things in on the sort of Life Sciences
front in terms of genetics and and
Medical Imaging and that these things
are sort of combining in a way that's
bringing about a host of transformative
changes across Industries
I would describe the fourth Industrial
Revolution
actually quite similarly to how to how I
would describe the past three and that
is
technology that leads to massive gains
and productivity and massive gains in
productivity mean substantial
improvements to everyone's quality of
life
[Music]
the world has been through revolutions
before the Advent of mechanization then
Electronics then the digital Revolution
all profoundly changed the world's
economies
but this revolution could be even more
disruptive
I think in previous revolutions you
could really talk about them as
industrial revolutions what was changing
was how things were made factories
industry often heavy industry in
particular here you're seeing
transformation across really a whole
range of not just industry but services
and and the creation of whole new
business models that didn't exist before
what's different a little bit about this
particular Revolution is that
um
it gets into a whole range of things
that people only thought were ever only
possible for humans to do job said we're
human jobs before aren't going to be
human jobs anymore
what if this fourth Revolution is
artificial intelligence the ability of
machines to match and perhaps one day
surpass the cognitive ability of their
human creators what's happening now is a
big deal it is making a big difference
in the way people live the way people
interact with each other it is sort of
obliterating distance it is in some
cases removing humans from tasks that we
once thought were the sole province of
the human mind these analytic tasks that
we thought only a human brain could do
we're suddenly finding that algorithms
can do that machines can do these are
early days in the Brave New World of
artificial intelligence but the
potential benefits are vast
what are some of the liberating benefits
of artificial intelligence they're
actually a lot if you think about
something just like driverless cars
autonomous vehicles which is one use of
AI that people are talking about that
could have a really liberating impact on
a lot of people's lives if you think
about older people who can no longer
Drive they're very shut in their houses
right now very dependent on others for
transportation with driverless cars they
would be able to go about their daily
life
and then you're seeing with big data
that this may have a profound impact on
drug development that you'll find new
Pharmaceuticals being developed at a
faster rate to cure diseases because the
computers are essentially able to sort
through the data and pick up connections
that otherwise would be missed
for health in particular the advantages
of machine learning data science are
immense those have an incredible chance
to address very both very infrequent
diseases and diseases which affect
different parts of the population very
differently if we're going to cure
cancer it's probably going to come
through data science
but there is potentially a darker side
to this technological Revolution one
which could profoundly change the world
of work as we know it
a technological Revolution will cost
jobs it'll cost jobs in the areas that
see the biggest advancements first a
good example of that that is feasible
over the near term
truck driving you have self-driving
trucks
you don't need the 3.5 million truck
drivers that you have right now in the
U.S what is key as part of this
revolution as productivity goes up as
the economy continues to evolve and new
jobs are created you need to make sure
those displaced workers are given the
skills to move into these new positions
but that's what's key will all of them
be no but I think the key point is you
need to make sure if you've lost 3.5
million jobs in one sector how do you
create more than that in another sector
and I think in past industrial
revolutions that's what we've seen
happen and hopefully and I think it will
it will be what happens again
but what if this doesn't happen
Martin Ford is a software entrepreneur
he has peered into our future economy
and sees a world where potentially
hundreds of millions of skilled workers
are out of a job
I would say that if you looked far
enough into the future there is no job
anywhere in our economy there's nothing
that anyone does that is completely safe
and that includes even artists and
novelists and you know the kinds of jobs
that you would imagine right now are
completely beyond the scope of
artificial intelligence millions and
millions of those jobs are going to be
lost and it's unlikely that enough jobs
are going to be created to absorb all of
those workers
[Music]
Martin Ford is a software entrepreneur
who has a chilling vision of the future
his best-selling books have put him at
the Forefront of a movement which
worries about technology the speed of
its growth and the immense potential it
has to change the world
this is the fourth Industrial Revolution
the Advent of machines powered by
artificial intelligence which have the
potential to make redundant hundreds of
millions of workers across the planet
it is a world which is nearly upon us
but which governments and businesses are
only starting to comprehend
well the central idea in my latest book
The Rise of the robots is that over time
machines computers smart algorithms are
increasingly going to substitute for
human labor I think that that's
inevitable technology is eventually
going to be able to do many of the
things the people now do and I think
there's a good chance that that will
result in unemployment it's going to
push people out of the labor force many
people are going to find it impossible
to adapt to that because they're not
going to have capabilities that really
exceed What machines can do and that's I
think going to be a genuine concern both
for our society of course and ultimately
for the economy too
[Music]
some of those machines are already with
us
foreign
algorithms that can interpret things
like body language and respond to some
extent to emotion that can determine
your mood for example and so forth and
and you know this has big implications
imagine what that could mean for example
for advertising if an algorithm can
determine exactly how you're feeling and
then Target advertisements at you based
on that
some of the language trans translation
things that have been demonstrated are
truly remarkable imagine if anyone in
any country who speaks any language
would now be able to do any job because
we have perfect machine translation in
real time between languages so you know
that has real implications for the job
market obviously
the effect on the wider economy in the
first decade of this Century the net
total number of jobs created in the
United States was Zero
what we see is that in the United States
we've been having
what we call jobless recovery so clearly
there's something happening there and I
think part of what's happening is that
jobs disappear when a recession happens
and then when finally recovery comes
back companies find that they're able to
leverage technology to avoid hiring
rehiring a lot of those workers and so
it's taking longer and longer for the
jobs to reappear
throughout history technology has always
disrupted economies and societies
in the late 19th century 50 percent of
U.S workers were employed on farms by
2000 it was less than 2 percent
those workers found work in other
sectors
but Martin thinks this time it's
different
what transformed agriculture was a
specific mechanical technology
now we've got a technology that's really
just ubiquitous it's across the board
artificial intelligence you is something
that's just scaling across our entire
economy it's not something that's
impacting just one sector is something
that literally is everywhere and as a
result it means that there isn't really
going to be any safe haven for workers
what makes the new technology so
ubiquitous is the development of a new
virtual world the world of Big Data well
Big Data essentially is the collection
and use of just massive amounts of data
and in big corporations for example
these companies are collecting all kinds
of information about their customers
about their business operations about
the actual processes in in industrial
environments and factories about the
things that their employees are doing
all of this data essentially becomes a
kind of feedstock for these smart
algorithms it it becomes the information
that they use to learn and and basically
to figure out how to do things and
that's something that is just going to
be I think dramatically disruptive going
forward
data stored on the world's computers is
now believed to be well over 1 000
billion gigabytes and it is big data
which is driving the most disruptive
advance in technology the ability of
machines to think
one thing that you'll very often hear
people say even today is that computers
only do what Their programs do you know
this is really not right anymore and and
the reason it's not right is basically
because of machine learning because we
now have this technology that allows
smart software algorithms to look at
data and based on that to to learn to
learn how to do things to figure things
out to make predictions so it really is
no longer the case that some human being
is sitting down and telling a computer
exactly what to do step by step
computers are now having the ability to
figure that out for themselves
you can imagine a future where every
device every Appliance all kinds of
industrial equipment everything
communicates and talks to each other and
I think that one of the things will
happen is that artificial intelligence
will kind of use that as a platform it
will scale across all of that everything
will become more intelligent
the last great technological Advance or
robots replace millions of blue-collar
jobs in factories and on production
lines Martin believes this new
disruption is going to Target the white
collar Workforce as well once a computer
learns to do something then that that
information can be scalable out to any
number of machines so it's almost as
like you can imagine having a Workforce
of people and you could train one
employee to do a particular task and
then you could clone that worker and and
have a whole Army of those workers
that's a bit like the way artificial
intelligence works so machine learning
is is very scalable if you've got the
kind of job where someone else another
smart person could maybe watch what
you're doing or study everything you've
done in the past and figure out how to
do your job then it's a pretty good bet
that eventually there'll be an algorithm
that will come along and be able to do
you know essentially that that same
approach so that's a lot of jobs
many of the jobs which might be
displaced are those currently occupied
by educated highly paid workers
so you can see really across the board
that anyone sitting in front of a
computer doing some sort of routine
predictable knowledge work for example
if they're cranking out the same report
or the same analysis again and again all
of that is going to be very susceptible
to this journalism is one interesting
area that's being impacted by this
because there are now systems that can
essentially tap into data and then they
can transform that data into a very
compelling news story that many people
would read and they can't tell that it
was written by a machine in the future
maybe 90 percent of new stories will be
machine generated
jobs displaced has the potential to
utterly transform the economic landscape
there have been a couple of studies done
most notably by a couple of researchers
at Oxford University and they've looked
at a number of countries and most of the
results have come back suggesting that
up to half of the jobs could be
susceptible to automation perhaps over
the next 20 years that 60 million jobs
in the United States alone
that's a staggering number and obviously
we have a massive social problem you'd
have tremendous stress on government in
terms of trying to take care of all
these people that no longer have an
income I think that you would see the
potential for a massive economic
downturn because you would run out of
consumers you no longer have people that
are capable of buying the products and
services that are being
produced by the economy
a revolution on this scale wouldn't just
transform an economy it would have
immense implications for our society
we could really have just what you might
call inequality on steroids the very
wealthy people who own all this
technology are going to do
extraordinarily well
you would have the potential for civil
unrest perhaps even riots or massive
crime waves
in the United States during the Great
Depression we had an unemployment rate
of about 25 percent and back then there
were many people genuinely concerned
that that would result in the collapse
of both democracy and capitalism
this situation amounts to just about the
end of the world as we know it a science
fiction nightmare straight from the
movies
there are some very prominent thinkers
like for example Stephen Hawking and
Elon Musk who have raised genuine fears
about the potential for advanced
artificial intelligence and their
concern is that someday we're going to
build a super intelligent machine
imagine a machine that's a hundred or
maybe a thousand times smarter than any
living person what would that system
think how would it act would it have a
use for us
it might decide that we're simply a
burden they might decide to just get rid
of us so it could potentially present an
existential threat is that something to
worry about I think that it's not a
silly concern it's not something that we
should laugh at and just dismiss
there's really no end point to this
there's no point at which you can say
this is absolutely as far as we can go
and there and machines will never go
beyond this we are reaching a new era a
time when things are going to operate
differently and we need to adapt to that
Healthcare is one area of the economy
already adapting to this disruption and
in this field researchers hope that
intelligent humans and intelligent
machines can work together for
everyone's benefit
[Music]
the fourth Industrial Revolution the era
of artificial intelligence has arrived
computers are now mastering tasks once
considered the sole Preserve of humans
and putting millions of jobs at risk
and now Business Leaders are wrestling
with the potentially huge implications
in general robots of one form or another
are going to become much more
omnipresent in our lives in a good way
they'll replace a lot of repetitive
activities that people are currently
doing robots will have a dramatic effect
on the labor pool lower the cost of
products people will start to realize
that just about every manual task
eventually will probably be done by a
robot
Martin Ford's books have highlighted the
threat to the job market but even he
sees areas where artificial intelligence
could be beneficial
I do think that Healthcare is actually
one of the areas where the impact of
artificial intelligence and Robotics
could be extraordinarily positive in the
future the burden on our economy is
growing at a remarkable rate especially
in the United States so if we can deploy
more artificial intelligence and
Robotics there to make that more
efficient that'll be a great thing
analysts expect the AI Healthcare Market
to generate revenues of over 6 billion
dollars by 2021 10 times its current
total
young companies like hindsight in New
Jersey and analytic in California are
mining data to improve patient outcomes
across a range of illnesses
and in New York IBM researchers have
developed Watson an intelligent Software
System at the Forefront of this
revolution
it can understand somebody's personality
type it can look at email for example
and tell you what is the tone of the
email or you know what kind of messages
are coming through whether you internet
them or not right it can look at for
example a big encyclopedia and extract
all the concepts of the relationship
among those Concepts
Watson operates in the world of Big Data
extracting Knowledge from the billions
of facts and figures floating through
cyberspace
I look at the world from the point of
view of you know the amount of data that
there is and the amount of knowledge
that is embedded or insights that's
embedded in the data that we're not able
to extract today and therefore we are
not able to make the right decisions
so
um for the Industrial Revolution to me
is the ability to have a much better
understanding of the world through all
of the data and therefore making better
decisions for it
IBM is currently running a research
project in which Watson augments the
intelligence of medical professionals
helping doctors treat the most dangerous
diseases in the world including skin
cancer
melanoma is a very deadly form of skin
cancer and it's something where early
detection and intervention is is key so
a dermatologist faced with a patient who
has a skin lesion will make some
assessment about the likelihood of a
lesion being melanoma
so unfortunately today dermatologists
can make errors some melanomas are being
missed
and some skin lesions which are
perfectly benign are being excised
needlessly
so what we can do here is essentially
ask the computer to make a deep analysis
over an image so this image is then
being sent to the computer and it's
being automatically analyzed and what
the computer is telling us about this
image is that there's a very high
probability that it corresponds to
melanoma what we're finding in our own
internal retrospective research is that
the computer can be as accurate as 95
percent
so this compares to the best clinical
experts today that are between 75 and 84
in recognizing melanoma it is not a tool
that would replace the clinical expert
rather it provides them with additional
analysis over the skin lesion images by
providing reaches into large databases
of similar lesions
[Music]
this is a vision of a future where
humans and machines work hand in hand
complementing one another's skills
I look forward to a time when you know
every professional in fact you know two
or three billion professionals around
the world are all able to have their own
personal cognitive assistant that can
help them do their daily jobs and that
changes the nature of expertise Humanity
would move to a completely different
place in terms of expertise and how we
apply our knowledge and our experience
into real world problems and therefore
make the world a better place just like
we've had machines that could augment
people's muscles in the in the prior
industrial revolutions or can help
people you know search vast amounts of
information like in the in the internet
era I look at the next Revolution as
machines augmenting people's cognitive
capabilities that's how I think about it
Martin Ford remains cautious believing
artificial intelligence is going to
fundamentally change the way we live and
work and challenge us like never before
we're not prepared for the disruption
that's coming
we're going to see things get worse
before they get better
in particular the impact on the job
market and the impact on the incomes and
the livelihoods for average people
so you know in the short term things
could be pretty difficult but in the
longer term if we do adapt to this then
I think there are reasons to be really
optimistic I mean you can imagine
an almost utopian kind of future where
no one has to do a job that's dangerous
or that they really hate or that's
really boring where technology takes on
more and more of that
and if we can get to that point of
course then that's a tremendously
positive outcome so I think that all of
that is really possible and it could be
one of the best things that's ever
happened to humanity but it will require
that we adapt to it and that's going to
be a staggering challenge
[Music]
this is the age of the city for the
first time in human history more people
live in urban than rural settlements
the world's Urban population is growing
by 70 million people each year
301 cities account for 50 of global GDP
this will rise to 66 by 2025.
so if we don't get things right in our
cities then the consequences for
Humanity are profound
cities are critically important to the
global economy and to progress in the
global economy
cities can be sources of chaos as well
as development
this dual personality of cities is what
makes them so alluring and so vital
they can be dangerous places
but cities are where fortunes can be
made
one of the primary factors driving
urbanization is opportunity you live on
a farm and you're growing crops you
don't have a lot of opportunity you see
a bustling growing city your friends are
moving there they're getting jobs and
offices maybe jobs in a in a
manufacturing center there's restaurants
there's culture there's life this this
is attractive this is attractive and
something you want to be a part of
and everything is relative you know
they'll have greater access to schools
greater access to health care greater
access to employment and a much less
vulnerable uh economic life
[Music]
in 1900 12 of the world's biggest cities
were in North America or Europe 100
years later this number had fallen to
just two most of the biggest cities of
the future will be in the developing
economies of Asia and Africa
most of the growth in cities is going to
be in China India and Nigeria those
three countries alone will account for
37 percent of the world's Urban
population just staggering numbers
here's an example Lagos the biggest city
in Nigeria
its population every year is adding the
equivalent of the population of Boston
[Music]
the urbanization rate in the U.S Japan
it's over 70 percent in China it's still
50 percent
so China may have a lot of mega cities
they may have a lot of larger cities but
those cities are either going to get
bigger or there's going to be more of
them so I think that's going to be a
trend and I think a lot of Emerging
Markets especially those with a large
populations are going to experience
trends like that in the next 50 years
this incredible rate of growth makes the
challenges of managing a large city even
more difficult
the biggest risks facing cities are the
same risks that challenge all of us
politically governance climate change uh
economic uh inequality productivity
economic growth employment education
Transportation those issues that that
face cities are the same that face
everyone except on a much in a much more
concentrated way
one City battling with many of these
problems is Rio de Janeiro in Brazil
Alessandra Orofino is on the front line
trying to solve them
she believes the world's biggest cities
are in danger of sinking under a tide of
poverty decrepit infrastructure and
citizens apathy and unless we do
something about it billions will suffer
the consequences
kind of urbanization that we have today
can only go so far if we do not change
the way we design our cities if we do
not make sales change with us you're
going to have very serious limits to
urbanization cities will become
impossible to manage impossible to live
in and just very miserable places to be
I think if we change that process those
limits could change dramatically and
potentially be non-existent but that
requires that we think deeply about the
environments that we want to be in and
how we can better build them together
managing mega cities is one of the great
challenges facing the world
this is Rio de Janeiro Brazil
nearly 12 million people crowd into its
metro area
it is beautiful and vibrant but it also
has its problems
crime
inequality
and poverty
Alessandra Orofino is an urban activist
and thinker who has lived and worked in
mega cities on three different
continents
she has worked with the United Nations
on its sustainable development goals and
founded the groundbreaking mayor Rio an
NGO that uses data gathered from
citizens to raise campaigns and solve
thorny issues posed by the rapid growth
of the city
mayor Rio has 170 000 activists and
Alessandra hopes it can become a model
for other rapidly growing cities around
the globe
we build upon a rich tradition of
neighborhood movements not only in
Brazil but all over the world and try to
sort of bring it to the 21st century in
a way that makes sense for people
I was born in this city in Rio de
Janeiro and my family has a very sort of
mixed background my father comes from a
neighborhood in Rio that was quite
dangerous in the 90s quite poor or lower
middle class and my mom comes from a
very wealthy background one of the best
neighborhoods in Rio it taught me that
this city can be amazing but it can also
be very rough and unequal and that's not
just a characteristic of this city I
think it's something that we are seeing
increasingly in cities around the world
[Music]
Rio de Janeiro is similar to many
emerging mega cities some neighborhoods
are as wealthy as anywhere on the planet
others remain impoverished and cut off
bridging this Gap will Alessandra
believes have profound benefits for us
all
cities bring people closer together and
they have this intensity in them this
density in them they're definitely the
places where most Innovation will
naturally happen because it's very hard
to innovate when you're always talking
to the same people and hearing the same
thoughts and studies are the exact
contrary of that they are natural hubs
for Innovation natural hubs for economic
growth and they tend to be the engines
of growth in most countries
but when this growth is rapid and
unplanned the results are gridlocked
streets poisoned air and an
infrastructure that simply cannot cope
well I come from a city that expanded to
rapidly for sure how do you create
sidewalks sewage systems schools
Mobility systems to cater to a growing
population
if that rapid Urban expansion is
happening in environments for inequality
is Paramount
the challenges are even bigger
in a mega City one of the biggest
challenges can be simply getting from A
to B
ability system items in general very few
exceptions suck
when you have a formability system you
just preclude entire segments of the
population from living the city from
actually accessing the opportunities and
the Beauties and the amazingness that
cities have right because it's very hard
for them to get around you also preclude
the rich people in the city from getting
to know other areas in the city which
can be incredibly exciting and a
fulfilling experience in and of itself
so you're creating a city in which
everyone is living in their own
territory which is terrible
at the Forefront of these infrastructure
problems are the cities poor they can
become physically cut off from the
economic opportunities that living in a
city provides the poor feather branch of
most things and I think that includes a
rapid expansion of cities the fact that
in the developing world one third of the
population is living in slums is
something that none of us should accept
as as we grow and as we think about the
planet in which we want to live
slums are a result of Rapid unplanned
expansion today an estimated 863 million
people live in slums
if the 104 million slum dwellers in
India were a separate nation they would
be the 13th most populous country in the
world
but slums are not always hopeless places
the poor not just sitting waiting for
the government to do something for them
they're creating their own Urban
environments so if you go to Islam in
Rio you see that most of that
infrastructure was built by the
community itself over the years so there
is a level of do-it-yourself a level of
initiative that you see a lot more
important neighborhoods and rich
neighborhoods precisely because the
government wasn't there
this means slums must be handled
delicately by urban planners
what do we do with areas that were
developed by communities but lack
infrastructure even if we're assuming
Good Will in terms of how we handle them
even if the only thing that we want to
do is provide those areas with good
quality public services that are choices
that need to be made in terms of which
pieces of that infrastructure do we
leave which pieces do we change knowing
that it was built by the people if we
don't handle that process in a way that
is human and intelligent and actually
aims at protecting the interests of the
poor communities we can end up with
massive waves of dislocation and and and
destroying an urban Fabric and a social
fabric that is so important and so vital
Henry we have a neighborhood called
Santa Teresa and in that neighborhood we
have a tram it's a historical Trend it's
beautiful uh most trams in Rio were
destroyed in the earlier in the 20th
century uh in Santa Teresa the neighbors
organized and kept their tram it's a
point of Pride for them was a forgotten
neighborhood for a while it became a lot
poor and then in the past five to six
years it has been gentrifying really
quickly and the government decided to
turn that tram which is one of the very
few remaining in the city into a tourist
attraction but what the neighbors said
at that point was the only reason why
this tram still exists and it's vintage
and kind of hipstery and amazing it's
because we organize and we kept it here
they created that value they created the
richness of that community and we took
that all over the world
Alessandra believed cities often ignore
this creativity the result is a
democratic deficit which erodes faith in
the city's government and alienates
already vulnerable communities
Alessandra believes cities must take
their citizens with them if they are to
expand successfully I think what we have
definitely not gotten right is the
process by which we involve citizens I
have not seen one case of a city that
has really used the collective
intelligence of its citizens and and
distributed power in a way that makes it
actually possible for people to
influence the way the city evolves and
when we get that that right I think will
solve a lot of the other issues that we
see
but for us to truly harness the power of
our cities we need to heal the divisions
within them first
if we keep building unequal cities these
are not sustainable and cities that are
not very good to live in for most of
their population I don't think we can
actually hope to be happy in these Urban
spaces the worst case scenario for the
global city of the future would be
cities that do not have a soul and
therefore become less and less
attractive to entrepreneurs to people
who do who do want to create new
economic activity and that ultimately
also become less wealthy
across the ocean from Rio another giant
city is growing Lagos is now the most
economically important city in Africa
but its growing pains are excruciating
and threatening the futures of 21
million people
more people live in cities than ever
before
but many of the world's biggest cities
are struggling to cope
[Music]
Lagos on Nigeria's Atlantic Coast is the
largest city in the world without a
city-wide rail system meaning everyone
has to travel by Road
for workers like Abraham Cole this means
his daily commute takes over his life
what time did you wake up
this morning I woke up like three
o'clock
3 3 30.
well I usually don't do breakfast
because it cannot Slow Me Down
yes the population of Lagos has nearly
doubled from 11 million to 21 million
but this staggering expansion has
overwhelmed the city's impoverished
infrastructure how long should it take
you to get to the office should take me
for the five minutes to get to the
office
but in full traffic in full rush hour
how long does that take your problem
would do like some six
seven hours in traffic three hours going
three four hours coming back it's much
worse coming back coming back is
is something else
and I don't think I want to waste seven
hours of my
everyday time
for the rest of my life
Lagos is currently ranked in the top
five least livable cities in the world
but although the city's economy is
bigger than Kenya's simply getting to
their desks is a daily ordeal for its
millions of workers
see your children
weekends
weekends only
sometimes
I see them during the week
if they really want to see me and
they're Keen to see me sometimes they
miss me that much it must be quite
difficult
yes it is but
it's what we have to do
for now
[Music]
like millions of legosian workers
Abraham's First Act on getting to work
in the morning is to take a nap
there we go
welcome to my office
so what are you going to do now I think
I have
yeah this is quite and it is 7 10.
so I took a nap for like 30 minutes
and get ready for walk
two thousand people migrate permanently
to Lagos every day straining the city's
infrastructure further and expanding the
city from the land to the Sea
[Music]
the result is slums like makoko a
floating settlement on the city's Lagoon
[Music]
the infrastructure has not kept pace
with the population growth so basic
measures of quality of life just as
access to clean water for example access
to electricity are are limited so before
you even get to issues related to uh
growth and and development
Lagos in Nigeria have to sort out much
more basic issues of infrastructure
makoco is the oldest slum in Lagos 80
000 people live here in buildings
sitting on stilts connected by a complex
system of canals
successful cities find ways to deliver
services to even the most uh uh most
deprived and that's that's the challenge
especially in the developing world where
resources are at a premium
in Moco residents have developed their
own infrastructure including fresh water
and electricity
and this three-story floating school
which doubles as a community center is
the latest addition to this unique
environment
the school was completed in 2013 it is
cheap and easy to build
designers hope it will become a template
for future buildings in Moco
in Nigeria raises interesting questions
of governance and control for example
It's been a uh uh long ignored area and
the local residents took charge and
tried to improve their own lot with
schools and with their own locally
initiated development projects however
the central government also has decided
it wants that area for its own
development reasons
only a few kilometers away lies an
alternative vision of how Lagos might
develop not a Grassroots Community
Vision but a grand project of incredible
scale
Echo Atlantic
well where we are standing we are in the
alignment of the financial district what
we call Echo Boulevard or some people
call it our Fifth Avenue this is where
all the major financial institutions
will establish their headquarters and
offices
[Music]
Echo Atlantic is a multi-billion dollar
residential and business district built
on 10 square kilometers of reclaimed
land it is in effect a new city
or it will be soon
its backers hope a quarter of a million
people will one day live here with a
hundred and fifty thousand workers
commuting from the old city across the
water
[Music]
when we
obviously we looked at
um
Canary wolf in London
we looked at Dubai and if you look at
the heart of London heart of Paris half
of New York
obviously the vast majority of the
residents are wealthy people I couldn't
afford to live in the heart of London
but it in creating the residents for
these people you're also creating job
opportunities
and it is the the norm here in Nigeria
that when you create a residential
apartment
you also create quarters for the
domestic staff working for that family
they have to take it into context that
this is a City development is not
allowing some assessment it's a business
center primarily this is the future
so the commercial development of Lagos
there's no doubt about it
David hopes the first residential units
will be open by the end of 2016 with the
infrastructure of the whole site in
place by 2022
projects like eco-atlantic raises many
questions as as they answer especially
from where local residents are aware
that they may be getting the short end
of the stick on the other hand they
really do lend themselves to uh
starting from scratch and being able to
build structures where there are
schools hospitals offices
Transportation facilities and they they
give gigantic cities like Lagos an
opportunity to create a model of what
can be presuming their their plan and
executed correctly
[Music]
so mega cities like Lagos remain
uncertain organic citizen-led growth
like Moco
or large-scale plan development like
Echo Atlantic what's clear is that left
unchecked growth could destroy cities
immense potential
I'm an optimist when it comes to cities
I grew up in New York City in the 70s
when the city went to the edge of
bankruptcy and here we are in the 21st
century and New York is is booming and
thriving and it's a tremendous place and
you can see with proper planning and a
diverse and vibrant population what's
possible
[Music]
I hope that those global cities will be
extremely interconnected in the sense
that they will have solidarity networks
in the sense that they will have
resiliency networks and in the sense
that their citizens will feel like their
cities where they want to be their
cities that is the sort of the project
that they want to build but they can
move they can visit each other they can
learn from each other at the global
stage
[Music]
the world of work is still dominated by
men
in the Middle East and North Africa only
25 percent of women are economically
active globally three-quarters of unpaid
work is done by women and even in North
American companies 25 percent of female
employees fill their gender has held
them back
if women are half the people they should
have you know a fair shot for all of our
benefit at contributing to the economy
in a way that is really much more equal
with men than maybe what we've seen in
the past of the biggest companies in the
world only about five percent are run by
women on corporate boards less than 20
percent of the decision makers that the
corporate board table are women right
now in the U.S Congress only about 20
percent of the elected officials in both
the Senate and the house are women women
earn about 79 cents on the male dollar
so there's all kinds of ways in which
women don't have parity in the world in
which we live
this is the gender gap and it's been
around for a long time
the organizations that have a lot of
power in our world the elected
government big companies the education
structure the medical systems all of
these things are really dominated by men
at the top and that's largely a result
of the history of the 20th century and
before that and it is taking a while for
women to break that what we call the
glass ceiling but at the same time it's
taking a while for the whole society to
adjust to seeing men and women as equal
actors at the top of any of these
institutions nearly 100 years after
women in the United States were
guaranteed the right to vote the gender
gap remains an issue in every corner of
the world
[Music]
and closing it has become more than just
an issue of fairness it has become an
economic imperative debated at Davos and
in boardrooms across the world
the gender gap matters for business you
know it's the it's the market
opportunity as well as the potential
loss to
to the bottom line when you have a
company in a Workforce that represents
your Market you're more likely to
succeed by having a more diverse
Workforce companies tend to be more
successful because they're able to more
creatively address challenges and issues
and you know in Innovation and so if you
have a board room or a committee
entirely composed of individuals who all
went to similar schools and have similar
backgrounds and think the same way
they're going to be less successful than
a very diverse board in a study that
came out last fall from McKinsey they
found in looking at a big Global number
of companies and looking at economies
around the world that in fact equalizing
women's economic contribution by 2025
would add 26 trillion dollars to the
global economy so you know there's
really very big numbers related to women
becoming more equal in terms of economic
participation wherever you look around
the world
evidence is mounting of the positive
effect female voices can have at the
very top of businesses if you look at
companies where you find female CEO or
chairwomen you know those are companies
where you don't have a poor corporate
governance they don't have poison pills
they don't have unequal voting rights
that keeps
Insider Management in control they don't
have staggered Board elections companies
with good governance are more likely to
have female CEOs
so the question is with the issue at the
top of the economic and political agenda
what is holding women back from the very
top is it lack of ambition or simple
old-fashioned sexism
so if we look at professional women in
the workforce about 43 percent of them
leave their profession at some point to
deal with care of most likely a child
but also a care of elderly relatives
it's very difficult to re-enter your
profession at the same level as your
male peers who have been present for
those last 10 years
[Music]
explanation Rings true for former senior
State Department official Anne-Marie
Slaughter she believes that what is
holding women back is the structure of
our workplaces and societies and if we
don't do something about it then our
corporations and governments will
continue to underperform there's no
Global issue that would not be helped
by advancing women or achieving equality
we want a world in which every human
being boys and girls has the right and
the ability to live up to his or her
god-given potential and what we have is
a world in which far more men have that
ability than women do
[Music]
Once Upon a Time women were promised
they could have it all but something is
holding women back from Gaining and
retaining the very highest positions in
business and government
Anne-Marie Slaughter has reached these
Heights in her career
two years he worked for Secretary of
State Hillary Clinton helping to shape
the long-term goals of U.S foreign
policy and now runs the Washington DC
Think Tank new America
but it was a 2012 article in the
Atlantic which he subsequently turned
into a critically acclaimed book which
cemented her reputation as one of the
most intriguing and thoughtful
commentators on the question of women in
power
the feminist movement is about equality
it's about women being able to have what
men have always had which is to be
fulfilled in a job to to be powerful if
that's what you want to do important
work or work that is Meaningful to you
and have a family too and I still
believe that women and men can do that I
think there's nothing that stops Us in
principle from doing that but what I now
say is we have to make really big
changes still if we're going to get
there because as work is currently
structured as we think about careers
currently structured far too many people
do have to make a choice and far too
many of those people are women
this was a choice which Anne-Marie
Slaughter had to confront herself work
in the state department at a high level
is work that depends on the state of the
world and the world is unpredictable by
definition and there's always too much
work to do if there's a revolution in
Egypt you can't say hold that I'll be
back on Monday you have to be there when
it happens so I definitely worked pretty
much you know very long hours for two
years when I went to the state
department my family understood that
they were going to sacrifice so that I
could do something I really wanted they
stayed in Princeton I worked in
Washington I left home at 5 a.m on
Monday mornings and I came back late on
Fridays and that was difficult but I
understood that that was what it took to
do this job my oldest son was entering
adolescence when I left and he had a
very stormy period
so much so that he started making really
quite bad choices a number of times I
would just jump on a train and go home
you know in the middle of the day and
then secretary Clinton was incredibly
understanding but after two years we
realized that it really was a choice
between
putting all our energy into helping him
get back on track with real important
life consequences
or you know getting promoted in a career
that I had I loved
decision to quit her dream job and leave
Washington didn't just affect
anne-marie's career it challenged the
feminist Cradle by which he had lived
her life
I saw the world
I realized that I had been telling women
for
for students whom I taught you can make
it work you just have to you know work
hard and you can make it work and I
couldn't make it work and if I couldn't
make it work with all the advantages in
the world I had money I had a husband
who was a lead parent I had every
possible way to make it work well then
you know then there are places where we
simply have to make choices that was an
epiphany
anne-marie's decision to put caring for
her family before advancing her career
saw her accused of betraying feminism
when I wrote my Atlantic article I got a
great deal of criticism from a women of
my generation or older who were feminist
women I admire but who very much worried
that I was setting the movement back if
I told people I'd come back because I
wanted to be with my family I got a
reaction that essentially told me among
many people and many women that they saw
me a little differently than they had
before that I wasn't really a player
that I'm I wasn't as motivated or
ambitious as they thought I'd been kind
of disappointed
anne-marie's experience sparked a debate
about whether women can have it all
Facebook CEO Cheryl Sandberg had
suggested that in order to get ahead
women needed to be more assertive in the
workplace in the face of male power they
need to lean in more
I admire Cheryl Sandberg and I admire
what lean in has done I've seen it as
somebody who runs an organization I have
seen young women come in and ask me for
raises and I know that they've just read
leave it you know that they're they're
doing it you know they're pushing
themselves forward in exactly the way
that Sheryl Sandberg recommends and many
women uh Advocate and I agree with all
of that I think it is a debate about
where to put the priority
Anne-Marie believes the problem lies
deeper not just in women's individual
Behavior but in a way business and
Society is structured to make it almost
impossible for women to have a career
and to care for a family at the same
time
that's a full-time job and somebody has
to do it and women have traditionally
done it so women are still expected to
do it so what you're doing is asking
people who are holding two full-time
jobs to compete with people who are
holding only one so if a woman is the
primary caregiver for her children or
for her parents and a full-time
Breadwinner she's competing with people
who are doing only one of those that's
like running a race and having half the
people you know put a pack of rocks on
their back and wondering why they don't
advance to the Finish Line at the same
pace
instead of saying well that's something
that women should still do while they're
also working we need to say parents
should have the time and the space to be
able to care for their children and also
work but that requires a much bigger
shift in thinking
the effect of the gender gap can be seen
across the global economy
rates of prime age employment for women
have been falling in the United States
for nearly two decades in 2014 Just 70
percent of women aged 25 to 54 were in
work
the comparable figure is higher in
Scandinavian countries and these are the
countries where the gender gap is at its
narrowest
the countries that have gone the
farthest toward real equality are the
Nordic countries Denmark and Sweden and
Finland and Norway
what they understand is both that you
have to recognize that raising children
is a social and economic investment and
their governments say we're going to
invest in maternity leave and paternity
leave and the paternity leave is
particularly important because they
create incentives for men to take not a
week not two weeks but up to six months
and they do that in part by giving one
month or sometimes two months as a kind
of use it or lose it so the man's an
idiot if he doesn't take the month to be
with his children when if he doesn't do
that he just he loses that leave right
that's crazy
if sharing the burden of care of
children and of parents is key to
closing the gender gap then that
suggests accepting the traditional roles
of men and women are a thing of the past
you have to be
accustomed to seeing men as the primary
caregivers of young children and men
have to understand that they're just as
good as women at this and even more
important or equally important in many
ways as a a Finnish CEO said to me they
had of a big finished company he said
now when someone comes a young man who
hasn't taken their paternity leave I
wonder about their character and that's
where we have to go
and in Scandinavia that's where they're
heading the Nordic nations are
pioneering a new approach to work and
Parenthood and narrowing the gender gap
in the process
[Music]
across the world women are reaching the
top in business and politics but they're
struggling to stay there
I call myself an impatient Optimist I'm
impatient because the world is getting
better for women but it's not getting
better quickly enough and we need to do
a lot to move that forward and I I would
love to tell you that because I'm a
female CEO I've changed the fabric of
the diversity makeup of my own company
and I'm leading by example but the
reality is is that we're challenged in
terms of female representation it's not
getting better in fact you know post the
crisis there was less diversity on Wall
Street than pre the crisis and one would
have thought it would have been the
opposite right so I would take the
opposite side not getting better and
it's costing Wall Street a lot of money
Anne-Marie Slaughter thinks this gender
gap exists because of the way businesses
and government treat family life in
Sweden along with its Nordic neighbors
attitudes are different Scandinavia
leads the world in gender equality but
its success has been hard one
I did the military service when I was 20
years old and we were three women in a
group out of 60 people I came in as top
10 out of 60 and a half marathon with 15
kilos on my back
and they said that I was lucky
and they continued to say that I was
lucky when I was at a shooting range or
did my exams well so my performance
wasn't valued as much as the guys
Sophia has made it her mission to
challenge this culture
Sweden is is viewed as one of the most
generical countries in the world and we
are if we look at you know legislation
the fact that you actually can combine
family and career and we see also that
we are are very above EU average when it
comes to women in the workforce but if
you look into the managerial positions
we are not there we drop out and we are
actually below the EU average I think
the eu's average is 27 female managers
and in Sweden we are 23.
foreign
's job is to help smash the glass
ceiling in the Swedish private sector
we're working with companies that were
constructed 100 years ago
so when they did recruitment where they
communicated whether they gave feedback
when they interacted with their clients
that did that in one certain way and
they still do it but the world has
changed so the glass ceiling is
basically old Norms old culture so you
have to change the culture to get rid of
the class really
80 percent of the global consumers are
women today and they are powerful they
have more money than before 64 percent
of the University graduates are women so
the future is female
if you don't know how to meet predict
their needs you will not be here
while Sophia tackles business culture
Swedish family life is already moving
towards parity between men and women
have they been Sophia splits the care of
her two children equally with her
husband Harry who also has his own
demanding career
for me as a CEO of another company
I work hard I get up early but I'm also
totally focused from five to eight on
the kids
we split 50 50 with the kids when when
they were small and before kindergarten
and this gives me the best of Two Worlds
I work hard I have a fulfilling job but
I also get to really know my kids
we have a
40 Years of career spending six months
with the kids is one of the best
investments you can do
this shared attitude to Parenting is
typical in Scandinavia TDC is one of
Denmark's leading telecommunications
companies with revenues of over 3.5
billion dollars in 2015. the company
offers generous parental leave to its
nearly 9 000 employees believing it to
be good for business as well as families
I definitely think that the the labor
market in Denmark compared to other
countries are much more free giving a
high degree of responsibility to our to
our employees and ask them to to to fill
the feel free to to have a whole life
and we see our employees as a and as a
human being as a whole 360 Degrees
around
TDC offers fathers 100 of their salary
during 16 weeks of paternity leave like
Sophia's work in Sweden the aim is to
change the culture around work and
families the result is a take-up rate of
85 percent and the company believes a
happier more productive Workforce
there's no doubt that we have seen
increased productivity levels for our
employees of course we can attract more
competent people because we have a more
balanced Focus for the job between your
private life and your your work life
that's that's for sure
your manager Peter jesperson is a
veteran of paternity leave he is able to
split care of their three children with
his wife Christine who then feels the
benefit in her own career
Peter is allowed to spend four weeks
with me at home right after the baby is
born and then when I go back to work he
has the per the first couple of months
he stays at home with the kids which
enables me to start working without
having any duties at home which then I
can focus on work
okay
and say that that what other countries
or and other people probably could be
missing out on is is is two things
probably I think
one thing is the family side I mean both
parents get to know their children they
get to know their preferences they get
to know who they are and I think on on
on the work environment and the
workplace I think there's numerous
studies that shows that equality if you
promote equality being both having women
in in top positions women's and managers
jobs and women in the workplace in
general uh you will you you will be more
successful so so as a as a society as a
whole
moves towards gender equality in
Scandinavia have not happened by
accident they're the result of a
deliberate long-running strategy I think
it's critical to how we live now and how
we go forward that the gender gap and
broader issues of diversity are part of
the conversation and that is really
because of the way the world is changing
the gender gap is part of it and it's
not going anywhere so it's important for
us to talk about it I want my daughter
to grow up in a world where she can be
anything so I think it's about you know
breaking norms and enable both men and
women to be who they are
gender equality is a huge piece
of cultivating and harnessing
human Talent and that's the way to think
about it that
we need all the talent we can find
because we have enormous problems
because we need economic growth because
we need Innovation because we need to
save the planet
we need human Ingenuity
creativity intelligence and half of that
Talent is in women
[Music]
foreign